data science is the intersection of
effective management of data
methods of analytics or statistical
analysis
and specialization domain which could be
anywhere between biological research
finance and marketing clinical business
internet of things
and the list goes on in the same way
bioinformatics
is at the intersection of informatic
sciences
statistical analysis and inference but
a specialization in biological data
and that biological data could mean a
lot of different things as well
interestingly biological data has been
evolving
over the past several decades especially
since
the completion of the human genome
project when the excitement about
finding genes responsible for different
diseases and phenotypes
has been growing we can see how this big
data
is especially accelerating during the
time of the pandemic for
example over the past several pandemics
like sars ebola mars
and zika virus small numbers of genomes
were collected
to study the genomic components of those
viruses
in the source cove 2 in the first
several months there has been a
three to four increase in that number
per month
and now we know that a huge variation of
genomic sequences and the
responses from the hosts the patients
that are
infected with this virus have been
studied so
we live in the age of high throughput
technologies
and one of those high throughput
technologies is next generation
sequencing the next generation
sequencing
allows us to study multiple levels of
our mixed data
about a particular biological phenomenon
phenomics
refers to the way things look
and how they are characterized at the
external level for example
we can look at one stage of a disease
and another stage of the disease
or how cell morphology tells us what the
cell type
is and all of those phenotypes
are collectively are referred to as
phenomics
genomics refers to the variation at the
genomic level so what kinds of single
nucleotide or multi-nucleotide
variations
we can observe at the level of dna
sequence
epigenomics refers to genome-wide
methylation patterns and different
modifications to histones which could
have
different tails that either make the
the chromatin compact or expanded and
potentially more available for gene
expression
and then finally gene expression itself
we can
look at different levels of gene
expression and different levels of
alternative splicing
or how different genes are combined
together from
exons to make actual transcripts
together
this onyx data has a very specific
property
it has to be processed from short reads
those
individual signals have to be assembled
into a data set
that describes the sample and in
biological research
this type of data could be used at the
clinical level
at the biotechnology or the lab research
level to understand
how different types of diseases
different types of conditions
could be associated with these specific
molecular
features now onyx logic provides
a complete roadmap for data science or
how to apply
data science specifically to biomedical
research data
including different types of phenotypic
data clinical data
and our mix data in this program you
will find
in this program you will understand how
to find data sets
explore them and visualize them how to
read papers and understand research
methods and
gain insights and understanding so learn
about the methods
and their application in the context of
these projects
so essentially it's a roadmap that will
guide you through from wherever you are
today
in terms of your understanding of omnics
data to the logic of
analysis and importantly this is a
project driven
process so we will introduce you to a
variety of different projects starting
from cancer diagnostics
to single cell and tissue composition
and
understanding of different features of
microbiome and infection
to do that we have designed a workflow
where we will study
experimental design how data is
generated and collected
how that data is processed to create
structured tables
how we can perform exploratory analysis
and start asking specific
questions about the data hopefully
leading us to meaningful biological
and reproducible results in the context
of the program
we will cover a lot of different methods
these methods include
data mining analytical thinking
statistical hypothesis testing
and classification for example we will
look at how we can take
a table of expression and start
comparing
multiple samples to each other based on
groups of samples
understanding the differences between
them but also understanding variation
within
groups of genes and samples as a result
we hope that you will see the
relationship between bioinformatics
or the way we apply data to biomedical
challenges
and the result of that which is
diagnostic
methodologies and novel therapeutics